نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مركزي رصدي الزلازل
الاورو متوسط ان زلزالا بقوه
5.2 هزه منطقه وسط تركيا امس السبت على
عمق عشره كيلومترات من جانب اخر قال رئيس
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه ان عدد
قتلى زلزال كهرما المراشر ارتفع الى اكثر
من اربعين الف شخص مضيفا ان عمليات البحث
عن ناجين ستتوقف اليوم الاحد
ربما نحن امام اكبر الكوارث التي واجهناها
في التاريخ فاضرار الزلزالين والهزات
والارتداديه التي زاد عددها على سبعه الاف
وخمسين الف هزه ارتداديه لم تكن مقتصره
على مدن الولايات ال11 المنكوبه للاسف
ارتفع عدد قتل الزلزالين الى
40,642 اعمال البحث والانقاذ عن العالقين
تحت الانقاض انتهت في معظم الولايات
ونعتقد اننا سننهي اعمال البحث والانقاذ
بحلول مساء الغد